so I got a lot of comments on my defense
of daa video and yeah a lot of them are
like this I just don't like the story
but here's the thing my point has always
been we don't know the story we all saw
the same teaser trailer that didn't
explain anything about the story all we
know is the very vague premise that the
characters have seemingly been wished
into being kids and that there seems to
be some menacing demon type figures
involved in some way that's it and even
that second part I'm not 100% on that is
not enough to understand the story in
any capacity I mean really that's barely
even a single bullet point in the
outline for what is likely to be the
very first episode alone will the
overarching plot and themes of di be
amazing I have no idea I can't say yet
because we haven't seen the story yet